Today, we are making
glue made out of food,
and putting it
to the test to see
how well it holds up against
commercially available products.
[Music]
Guys, everyone knows
about Elmer's Glue, super glue,
lots of regular glues
that you're going to find
around the house,
but did you know
that you can actually
make these at home?
That's right.
Glue has been around
for a lot longer
than the Elmer's Glue company,
and we wanted to take a look
at some recipes that we found
that might have worked
for older types of glue,
and see how they compare to
what we're using from the store.
Now, I think it's safe to say
that not all glue
is created equally.
You do not get the same results
with Elmer's glue that you do
with say a super glue.
But there are lots
of variations of recipes
that you can make at home.
So we want to try them out.
Glue has been around
since approximately 70,000 BC,
when cavemen would use
glue made out of tree sap
as a protective coating
for cave paintings.
Around the year 2,000 BC,
Egyptians started using
a liquid glue as an adhesive
in their wooden artifacts.
In 1932, Elmer's
Glue was introduced,
and became a staple
of the industry,
and still is today.
Here's the basic idea.
Using common household
ingredients, most
of which are food,
we're going to make a variety
of different types of glues,
and see how they hold up against
their commercial counterparts.
So for our first glue,
we are going to go with
the most basic of basic recipes.
This is probably one
that used to use
in preschool or kindergarten.
It's just flour paste.
You need that,
and you need water,
and that's it.
So for flour paste,
if you've never used it,
this stuff is really good
for simple paper crafts,
or even if you're putting
up posters outside,
and you don't want to use
any sort of toxic glue.
This stuff is wonderful for it.
Making this glue is the easiest
it could possibly be.
You're just going to mix water
and flour together
until you have about
a cake batter consistency,
and then throw it on the stove
until it boils.
Now, we're going to be making
multiple types of glue.
So just to keep them separate,
and keep track of them,
we're also going to add
a little bit of food
coloring to each of them.
This one's going to be green.
Sort of green.
Yellowish green.
Maybe I need more food coloring.
Well, it's definitely
sticking to itself.
We made guacamole glue.
It does look like guacamole.
While our first glue recipe
is cooling down off the stove,
we're going to be starting
in our next one.
This recipe calls for water,
corn starch, 2 tablespoons
of corn syrup, and finally,
1 teaspoon white vinegar.
This glue recipe is supposed
to end up quite thick,
almost the consistency
of a glue stick.
In the past, we've done
some stuff with glue sticks
where we took a lot of them,
and we put them
in a George Foreman grill.
It was a lot of fun.
Those glue sticks were purple,
and I think we're just going
to carry on with that theme.
We've got a green glue.
Now, let's do a purple glue.
Now we put this on the stove,
heat it up, and mix it
until it gets thick.
[Music]
It almost looks exactly
like our melted glue sticks.
It does look very similar.
Okay, making that was
fairly interesting.
I spent maybe four
or five minutes stirring.
It was on medium heat.
Most of the time
I was stirring it,
it was really thin.
It was like the
consistency of milk,
although, you know purple,
because we added
the purple food coloring.
But it's just thin, thin,
thin, then all of a sudden,
I saw it starting
to sort of blob up
on the end of the spatula,
and I was worried
I'd done it wrong,
but I just kept stirring,
and the whole thing
thickened very quickly.
All right, so we
have got our two types
of homemade glue here.
This one is just
regular craft paste.
So it doesn't have
the strongest sticking power,
but we're still going
to put it to the test
against Elmer's Glue.
The other one
that we've got here is
technically glue stick glue,
and we want to compare that
to glue sticks itself as well.
So what we're going to do
is were actually going
to have a weight test.
Nate has a scale,
and we are going to hang stuff
from the glue itself,
and actually see just
how much weight this stuff
can take before it breaks.
[Music]
Okay.
Now, I think we need
to let these dry,
and while we're letting
these dry, we can try
are other types of glue.
So the glues we've made so far
are very water soluble as are
their commercial counterparts.
So the glues were going
to make now should
technically be waterproof.
We're going to make one
that's a little bit simpler,
and then one
that should be strong
enough to mend broken glass.
But we're going to put
those to the test.
So this first one we're going
to do is going to be glycerin,
water, gelatin, and vinegar.
So you're going to start with
6 tablespoons of cold water,
and then two packets
of unflavored gelatin.
Now, we're going to put
this on the stove,
and we're going to heat it up
until the gelatin
has dissolved completely.
Alright, so we've got
the gelatin all dissolved.
Now, we're going
to take it off the heat,
and we're going to add two
tablespoons of white vinegar,
and a teaspoon of Glycerin.
And we're also adding just a bit
of yellow food coloring.
So we can keep all
of these separate.
You do want to use
this glue warm,
but we want to make sure
that it's cooled
just enough to touch,
and then we'll be
able to use it.
So we are going
to make one more glue
that's supposedly tougher
than the rest.
Now, this is a waterproof glue.
The other two that we have
our craft glues and paste,
but we're going to try one
that is specific
for holding glass together.
Starting off,
we're taking three tablespoons
of fat-free milk,
and we're going to heat
that up on the stove.
You want this almost to boiling,
but not quite.
While Nate is heating
up the milk,
I'm going to mix 2 tablespoons
of cold water with two packets
of gelatin again,
get those as dissolved as we can
before we add the milk.
So perfect.
Yeah, we're starting
to get a simmer,
so we can take that off,
and we're going to mix that
directly into our gelatin mix.
So this recipe
is both waterproof
and supposedly strong enough
to hold together glass.
But it does have milk in it,
so it will spoil
if you don't use it immediately.
One way that you
can actually kind of combat
that is you can add
some peppermint extract.
Keeps it from spoiling.
So I think that means
we need some glass
that needs to be glued,
and right now, we've got glass
that doesn't need to be glued.
So...
We're going
to break some stuff.
We're not exactly sure
how high up we need
to hold these to drop them,
and have them
break their concrete.
So we're going to start low,
and work our way up.
So these are thicker
than your usual glasses,
and they're made
of borosilicate glass,
which is going to be
a little bit harder
for us to break than soda lime,
but we're going to try it.
Okay, I'm going to go
up to about a foot.
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
Something broke.
This one's broken.
Oh, mines in pieces.
All right, we get about 1 foot.
That one sounded
like it exploded
into lots of pieces.
That one will never be
a glass again.
[Music]
All right, which glue do we
want to use on which cup.
So let's go from what we
think will be the strongest
to the weakest.
So I'm going to say
super glue for the worst.
Let's go ahead and take
our glue made specifically
for glass to this piece,
and then our one
that's almost intact,
we'll go ahead and use
our waterproof glue for.
[Music]
All of our glue has had
plenty of time to set,
so now we need to see
how well it's working out.
I think first,
we can take a look
at our glass glues,
compare those, see
what we've got,
and we've actually done
multiple tests with the glues.
For instance, I also
glued these two pieces
of glass to each other,
and this piece of paper on here
to act as sort of a label
that you're putting on a glass
jar or something like that.
There's our breaking
point right there.
Just removing the tape
on that one,
it was too much for this.
And this is the one
that the recipe said
it was specifically
for glass, right?
It did.
Yeah.
That's what's so confusing.
Now, this recipe,
you're supposed to use
at room temperature,
which is why it's
so gelatinous to glue glass
to other pieces of glass.
Put a little bit
of pressure on this that,
just right off.
You got those two pieces
all right together.
The recipe I found
actually told you to keep
it room temperature.
That's what all this is.
That's what fell apart.
I wasn't having it.
So I superheated it.
And this one that's
actually staying together.
Yeah, that's actually
holding really well.
I'm going to try
and break it off.
All right, so one
was able to come apart,
but so much more
resistant than like,
that has almost no resistance,
it just falls right off,
heating it up.
So when this is
like nice and hot,
and very liquid,
it actually does an okay job
of securing the glass together.
So room temperature,
this is just two pieces
of glass glued to each other.
Let's see how well that holds.
Not really.
Virtually, none.
Might be good
if you're just trying
to like keep a piece
of glass from sliding off
another piece of glass.
I'll see this goes.
Go with this one,
see how well
that comes to pieces.
It's already so much stronger
than mine was.
It does have the advantage
of being all together,
so it's just every side
is being supported.
I'm gonna try and break
that apart now.
See mine just snapped apart.
[inaudible]
Okay, so I was able
to put a little bit
of pressure on that,
and it's coming apart,
but it's still tacky too.
Mine is not even tacky anymore.
Okay, there we go.
Once you've got one piece off.
They're all just
gonna fall apart.
This glue was meant to glue
glass to other pieces of glass.
This type of glue was simply
meant to be waterproof.
So I'm curious about
our little paper label.
We both had labels
attached with our glue.
Let's see how well
this is attached.
So this is just
a piece of paper.
It did come off fairly easily.
But it also was staying on it.
Nothing was pulling that off.
It was sticking pretty nicely.
Now, this is fun.
This is actually pulling off
like how I've seen a lot
of cooking labels.
This is actually how I've seen
labels peel off before,
and this is--
Even leaving some behind.
Yeah.
Out of these two glues,
which one would you use?
I would definitely go
with the yellow one.
It definitely seems more useful,
easier to use
by a little bit,
and a little bit stronger.
My superglued cup
is just a huge mess,
still missing big old pieces,
because it broke
quite a bit.
I couldn't get
everything back together.
Some bits are still missing.
I think.
Wow.
Okay.
That actually just
broke the glass again.
That didn't come
apart at the glue.
This is where it was glued,
and here is a new break
that I just put into it
by pulling it apart.
Superglue, better or worse
than our homemade glues?
I have to say better.
Superglue actually has
ingredients that we
don't just have lying
around the house usually.
Can you order them?
Yes.
Is it possible to make?
Yes, but for convenience sake,
I would say reach
for the Superglue.
We've got non-glass type glue,
and we've built some tests
for that as well.
I think it's time to see
how they hold up.
I want to start
with our homemade flour paste,
and then I want to compare
it to Elmer's Glue.
Wow.
[Music]
Oh, it didn't break the glue,
it broke the paper clip.
I'm just gonna hang all
of my weight from this.
You ready?
Oh!
See, that time,
it got to four pounds.
I like our old result better.
We got over 20,
and I kind of wonder
if just by pulling it twisted,
just a little bit--
I think so.
I think it,
and it also hit the ground so,
it could have, you know,
cracked a little bit.
That's interesting
for a couple reasons.
When you're pulling
straight apart,
when we were adding weight,
or you're pulling straight down,
it held a lot of weight,
and that actually reminds me
of something similar.
This is a paper bag
from the grocery store.
These handles here,
they're glued on.
It's just paper glued to paper.
And if you pull
straight up on them,
you can put quite a bit
of weight in these bags.
In fact, it even
says on the bag,
pull handles up, not out.
So pulling straight
up on these bags,
you can get quite a bit
of weight going.
But as soon as
you pull sideways,
they come off so easily.
But we got at least
25 pounds pulling straight down
with our first glue.
Let's move on to
our so-called glue stick glue.
[Music]
What did we get to?
I didn't see that time.
I didn't either.
Hopefully, Mark caught it.
When we did our video
with tons of glue sticks
in the George Foreman grill,
I have never been super
satisfied with the performance
of a glue stick
in gluing things together.
However, now we're going
to see how it does
in our fish scale test.
[Music]
14.
I think that was at 14 pounds.
Both of our homemade glues
are almost doubly as strong
as the glue stick glue.
Elmer's Glue.
Now, this is the one we
both thought was going
to be the best.
>> Holy cow.
>> That's 40 ...
50...
Oh, we maxed out this scale.
We have a solution to this.
[Music]
Holy cow!
I think I saw
that at about 55-60.
Oh, it didn't break the glue.
It tore through
the popsicle stick.
[Music]
Glue made out of food at home.
It is doable,
and we got some
pretty awesome results.
So with our glass glue
and our waterproof glue,
it's going to work pretty well
if you've got some light crafts,
you're working with kids,
but I was very impressed
with our homemade flour paste
and stick glue.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got
more fee to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video.
That box of the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to subscribe to the club.
Don't forget to ring that bell
so you never miss
out on the fun,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.